We had a really
tough year this year.
The Yukon River is kind of
our life blood here,
and we no longer have it
as an option for getting food.
So we're relying on getting
moose, bears, and caribou.
We had no luck
getting the moose this year.
The caribou have not
shown up in this country
until just recently.
So Denise and I
are on the hunt.
There's fresh caribou tracks.
I'm seeing a lot of sign today.
We just had a fresh snow
last night,
so anything that we see
out on the trail right now
is gonna be fresh.
So this is pretty exciting.
It looks like there's
at least two, maybe three.
Small band.
Small bands are harder to hunt.
They're a lot more wary.
So I'm hoping
I can kinda come up
on some that are maybe grazing.
And if we can do that,
I might have a chance
of getting a little bit of meat.
We're just gonna keep
poking our way upriver
and see if we can't find one.
Get a shot.
I'm at a big disadvantage
right now.
We're on a small river
that has a lot of bends
and so you come up on 'em
before you can
really see 'em to stalk 'em.
So, it's really challenging.
DENISE BECKER:
The animals notice
absolutely everything.
They're extremely in tune.
The only chance
we're gonna have
when we're on snow machines
is to come up to a corner
and get a long view down
where they haven't had
a chance to hear us yet.
ANDY (off screen):
I just ran into
a bunch of caribou.
They came out this way and then
they went back this way.
They heard Denise and I
before we could get
the machines stopped.
Looks like I scared the (bleep)
out of those caribou.
There's a bunch of 'em.
Well, not a bunch.
It looks like maybe
five or six or whatever.
DENISE: Nice.
ANDY: A few more seconds,
and maybe we would
have got a shot off.
It would have been
an awful long shot though.
It's really hard to hunt caribou
in this kinda country
because it, like,
they're so fast.
-DENISE: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-ANDY: You know.
Thirty seconds
and they're in this brush
and you'll never see 'em, so...
-DENISE:
Well, let's keep going.
-ANDY: Yeah.